SO WE ARE JUST ABOUT SET TO GOAN
SIMON BENEWAH WHO DRAWS BACK IN.
AFTER BEING A HEALTHY SCRATCH ON
THURSDAY
NICK DESLAURIERS THEY WIN THE D.
SHATTENKIRK T TENRIQUE
GOT IT AWAY QUICKLY.
TERRY
HE SPENT TIME WITH THEOING TO SE
USES THE ANAHEIM DEFENSE AS
>> Brian: GOOD JOB BY THE
PENALTY KILLERS.
I TALKEDZEGRAS COMES IN, THROWST
BEEN GOOD BUT THE DUCKS HAVE NOT
HAD THE KIND OF PRESSURE ON THIS
POWER PLAYCH HIM IN PRACTICE, JT
WIN STREAK, JOHN GIBSON SITS
SO CERTAINLY, TWO VANCOUVER
DEFENSEMEN THE D
FOWLER INTO THE MIDDLE OF THE
ICE FAKES THAT SHOT, HANDS IT
OFF..
THEY ARE JUST GOING TO THROW IT
DOWN TO MOMENTS AGO
WITH A QUICK PASS OUT FROM THE
CORNER.
>> John: SPENDINGWHAT A ROLE HE.
HOW ABOUT THE COMPARISON FAR SI.
MILANO COULD NOT FORCE I I.
WATCH AS Z TALK ABOUT
WITH TWO GOALS AND AN ASSIST.
8:20 TO
>> John: HUNT WITH A SHOT PAST
THAT WILL END
SEASON AGO, BOTH IN POINTS AND
INSILFVERBERG COULD NOT CONNECTN
THE.
BUT ON THE OTHER SIDE OF THINGS,
TALK ABOUT
FORWARDS.
>> John: TERRY ON THE BACKHAND
THE MIDDLE,
KNOCKED DOWN AS IT IS POKED AWA-
>> Brian: COUPLE OF PUCKSKSHE L.
GIVE AND GO.
MYERS, HIGH SHOT OFFCK FOR TROYD
HAVETO TERRY, LAYS IT
BACK.
LINDHOLM HAZARDED OFF THEE GAME.
ONE OF THE BETTER MUSTACHES ON
BOY, THEY DESERVED IT.
THEY PLAYED WELL THIS GAME.
GOOD TO